مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيد
نوفا
[موسيقى]
الوقت للاتحاد اتعاقد فيه مع بنزيما
والاهلي جاب محرز وجاف فرمينو وجاف
الانسان ماكسيمان
وجاب عدد من اللاعبين الهجوميين الى حد ما
الهلال لحد الان ما ابرم صفقه هجوميه
مقنعه الان طلع صحفي المختص بسوق
الانتقالات فبريزو رومانو وتحدث عن ان
الهلال حاب يتعاقد مع جوان فيليكس ولكن
جواو فليكس هو مش صفقه توب بالنسبه للهلال
هو مش لاعب من الفئه اي او كلاس اي من
اللاعبين اللي الهلال لازم يطمح انه
يجيبهم لحتى يرجع ويكون قادر ينافس الموسم
الجاي على لقب الدوري وينافس على لقب دوري
ابطال اسيا لاحقا الهلال اليوم عم يعتمد
على مالكم بالهجوم ومالكم بمباراه الاتحاد
مشت الامور وسجل هدف وخاصه المباراه
بثلاثيه ولكن مالكم مش اللاعب اللي بيقدر
يلعب لك فورس 9 او مهاجم وهمي ولا هو
اللاعب اللي بيقدر او مهاجم صريح لذلك
الهلال بحاجه ان يحدد خياراته هل هو بحاجه
لاعب فولت ولا بحاجه لاعب تارجتمان واذا
كان بحاجه فورت نايت او
فبالحالتين الجواب فليكس مش الخيار الافضل
جواب فليكس عمره تقريبا صار 23 سنه ولحد
الان اوروبا كلها ومعظم متابعين كره القدم
بيتعاملوا معه على انه لاعب صغير ناشئ
يعني وانه لازم ينعطى فرصته وبعده ما ادى
وبعده ما عملوا ولكن على سنوات طويله جواب
فليكس مع اتلتيكو مدريد ما قدم اي شيء مع
منتخب البرتغال ما في اي شيء يذكر طيب هل
لما انتقل على تشيلسي على الدوري
الانجليزي عمل شي كمان لا
وبالتاليكس يعني هي موهبه دفنات قبل ان
تظهر او قبل ان تظهر افضل ما لديها ممكن
يقدم اداء جيد اذا اجعل هلال احتمال ولكن
اعتقد انه مش لازم يكون هو طموح الهلال
طموح الهلال لازم يكون لاعبين اكبر من ذلك
اللي كان عم ينافس على التعاقد مع ميسي ما
بيجي بالنهايه بيتعاقد مع جوعه وفليكس
اعتقد انه في خيارات مهمه جدا بالنسبه
للهلال بسوق الانتقالات ممكن انه يفكر
فيها وممكن انه يعني يعتبرها ضمن الاوبشنز
الموجوده للموسم القادم في مهاجمين نحن
لحد الان ما عرفنا صفقه شو صار فيها كان
على اساس انه على وشك التوقيع وبعدين ما
عرفنا شو صار اختفت الانباء تماما وما في
اي اخبار عن متروفيتش هو صفقه ممتازه جدا
للهلال لانه تارجت مان ممتاز جدا جدا جدا
اما فالحقيقه لحد الان ما حدا عارف هو شو
مركزه بالملعب ولا شو الادوار اللي
بيؤديها ولا شو اهميته للفريق بشكل عام
لذلك سميوني كان راكنوا على الدكه ومعه
تشيلسي الموسم الماضي مثل ما حكينا ما
قدمت اي شيء اعتقد انه لسان حال الهلال
اليوم انه ربما محتاجين لاعب
اعلى شويه من اجواء فليكس او يلبي مستوى
التوقعات والتطلعات للموسم المقبل وتقدر
تنافس فيه الصفقات الخرافيه بقيه الانديه
نعم هناك اليوم ضوء على ماني وعلى رونالدو
وعلى بنزيما ولكن في لاعب ما حدا منتبه له
اسمه الان سان ماكسيمان اللي كان واحد من
افضل الاجنحه بالدول الانجليزي على مدار
الموسمين الماضيين لولا الاصابات ولولا ان
نتعرض لشويه مشاكل ولا كان ممكن يكون
بنادي اوروبي كبير ويكون واحد من نجوم
الكره الاوروبيه سان ماكسيمان ومستويات
كبيره قدرات كبيره عنا رياض محرز عنا
فرمينو عنا بنزيما وعنا اسماء كبيره
وبالتالي الهلال محتاج للاعب اكبر واهم من
جواو فليكس هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض
الصافي حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا
بالف خير